how's the gum red when it's paired about
it's really late I'm super tired but
we're gonna play a little bit of the
dead lab some spooks before we go to bed
isn't that right
it's Monday tomorrow that's gotta suck
it might even be Monday when you watch
this here we go
dead lab thank you for coming today
you're welcome darling Justin thanks oh
it's quite see the blood is going upside
down I don't think it's safe oh now it's
down what the hell is it a bug I think
I'm looking through a pipe aah aah April
1st you're in the Uni lab six-level
47:57 it's right there how do you know
my name which effects in what do you
want me to do I did not have sex with
the press okay all right
well this game looks surprisingly cool I
mean the graphics aren't the best but it
has voice acting that that ladder is
broke though spor ladder
poor poor ladder look at it hey it's not
too shabby I like it that's kind of cool
okay yeah how do i how do i how do I had
a whole Doha okay friend gasps huh well
you're looking at it follows me oh you
can't see me that
you don't know [ __ ] bro you don't know
[ __ ] oh I can climb it I can climb a
broken ladder best game ever can attempt
but my head is stuck best game ever
attended a I can't go the ladders worst
game ever ten out of ten random blood in
corner and my urinating what okay you're
not [ __ ] around
why is oh oh that's why oh it went
through the wall okay cool cool I know
the where the wind is coming from that's
kind of how do I turn on my flashlight
ah thank you game names jeff' la doctora
hell birthday okay we're fine
sis rats rats that can teleport and go
through walls what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] rats I think I missed the jump
scare but it was just as effective oh my
[ __ ] tits oh my God my nipples are so
hard right now oh god oh god just make
it stop Megan Fox please shut up
really shut up I'm trying well chef lava
[ __ ] ell that was loud okay we need
to go here I think [ __ ] me Matt oh we
need to go there okay [ __ ] a dick in a
stick yeah physics oh yeah
oh the vent but their words rats it's
disgusting
control the crowd chant don't you dare
jump scare me bruh no jump scare well
[ __ ] me I'm standing what do you want
from me game yep
I'm staying on the crates from now on
you better watch oh there's another one
of these I probably need it
nice Maira way petia here shift the
sprint why would I need to sprint why
would I need
that's a hella better what what what oh
as a fire I really do believe the
everyday really then what the [ __ ] is
that
it's a [ __ ] crab it's a [ __ ] crab
it's a [ __ ] grab it's not that bad
it's not that bad oh oh man I said I
don't know why I'm so [ __ ] scared
it's not even that scary pull your [ __ ]
together man pull eat where are you
I just came a little better where are
you God off any held back that a badass
I'm such a wimp today what's wrong with
me the sons are scaring me don't get
Timmy name shut up I'm not afraid I am
badass let me pick you up where are you
going you piece of box don't jump in
front of me box all right whatever
where we going what are we doing up
there yes of course yes of course you
guys say dead idiots
whoa box don't jump box what did I tell
you about jumping I'm happy I felt like
that's not even English is it as it is
we're talking about okay I picked
something up can I read it
I can't great
all right Tessa you're my best friend
right now don't [ __ ] with me anyone here
anyone want to [ __ ] with me huh I would
love to [ __ ] with you I mean you know
that's that's not okay we don't we don't
have sex estate job love commit oh my
god you stay or it's a gem like axilla
yep love it though okay
the ambience is so I'm an alumna how is
that a jump-scare high my jump ski I'm I
usually don't play games this late at
night I guess that's what's okay
tick hammer for shot what I have a shout
a way my shoddy way my Shawnee I was
specifically promised a shouting where
you at shall we bring it on jump-scares
bring it on
the [ __ ] of this [ __ ] when Luna near a
[ __ ] has hobbits door locked
what the [ __ ] did that [ __ ] come from
bring it on alright we're fine char a
bit you set the crane bet I bet I open
the door my zipper to get some health
just like real laughs what am i doing
I'm stuck
but to hell him suck as a crab it said
control to stand up but it's not under
working
hi it's working okay which store did I
open that's the [ __ ] question it's
probably one over here so slow with this
[ __ ] Shaunie what if we jump is that
working I'm a kangaroo now mmm-hmm [ __ ]
it's at the club why do I keep saying
that okay no one underneath the sash no
one behind me no one in front of me no
one above me you [ __ ] jazz nuggets
don't spook me don't spook me let me
reload reload before we go in there and
then we're not gonna spook fierce hug
the walls pets hug the wall hello friend
just kidding you are not my friend they
fall for it every time
all right reload reload we're gonna do
this [ __ ] for us I'm gonna [ __ ] power
through this [ __ ] that's fine
it really is we're doing great I am
proud of you you're not doing anything
besides watching but really you should
name the phone okay come on come on come
on
watch my flashlight give me my
flashlight flash I said flashlight
I said flashlight you don't hear me
correct I stutter when I'm scared okay
American run at least you jävla as a fan
a helmet as jävla bulla Nicole calm down
calm down calm down calm down
yes good today let's go honey mama
commitment oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey I'm sure Sam
Sam and his lamb
eight his boomerang bamboo tag or you
guys can't even oh [ __ ] bring it bro
bring it on I'm a kangaroo [ __ ]
I'm a kangaroo [ __ ] yeah that's right
I'm the best kangaroo this town has ever
seen look at them smooth son
look at her moves it sounds all you
[ __ ] got hop no [ __ ] it isn't well
doesn't even matter I'm the best
kangaroo in town mother [ __ ] BAM yeah
that's right
you may have hit one of my left nipples
but that's okay with me I actually like
it I endorse that [ __ ] all right pip get
it
high-five good job proud of what in not
so loud place okay thank you thank you
thank you thank you don't like this that
makes three of four of us [ __ ] that is
one sexy ass [ __ ] all right this is a
demo I think yeah I think that was a
demo and rashugal I know it sucked
sorry sure glad my bad one-man army 3d I
really actually surprisingly good I hope
we finish it whatever it is it was fun I
don't know what else to say it was
perfect for tonight I'll be able to
enjoy watching hope you didn't get too
spooked out let me like if you did
it's a sky cover birthday and I see you
and your beautiful tits tomorrow doesn't
love you
[Music]